I'm not asked on that many podcasts but
I've been asked on probably 10 podcasts
this year I've said no to every single
one because I was like What if I have a
panic attack
the social media Superstar is Casper
Casper is one of the OG YouTubers he
became an internet sensation it was kind
of in the very beginning I feel like
creators were kind of Misfits he started
the company influencer he's also started
his own management agency with Joe Sugg
who you also might be familiar with he
does a bunch of philanthropic things as
well and he's also recently started a
venture capitalist fund a successful
business is 60 the right Market 30 the
team and 10 like the unique idea but
everyone's like just think come up with
a perfect idea it's not you can't
predict the future now this conversation
is interesting because Casper is like
one of the OG gang from the from like
the olden days of YouTube and so we talk
a lot about what that experience was
like what it was like growing up in
South Africa and watching all these
YouTubers and then being able to
collaborate with them and then
interviewing people like Ed Sheeran and
this sort of immensely like Jet Set
lifestyle that Casper was leading back
in the day I was like 1920 and like
people would say what are you doing or
my grandmother would be like what do you
doing with your life and you're like
well I'm a YouTuber this is my job and
they're like well what's your real job
and to be honest the the time my
grandmother actually understood it was a
job worth pursuing was when I met the
queen for the first time we talk about
some of the downsides of Fame and
attention and some of the issues with
burnout that YouTubers and other
creators kind of have amongst other
people and we talk about his Evolution
from kind of entertainment vloggy type
YouTuber to kind of business tycoon
investor entrepreneur philanthropist
type Chap and what that Arc was like so
I hope you enjoyed this interview as
much as I did just a very quick thing
before we get started if you have not
yet subscribed to the podcast either on
YouTube or in your favorite podcast app
of choice then please do it really helps
us out a lot Casper use that use that
content thank you so much for coming on
thank you it's gonna be interesting um
you are like one of the OG YouTubers who
started in 2010 and made videos all the
way through to 2019 and you're like my
age so you would have started used to
study YouTube at the age of like it's
getting older we're getting old I know
like all these gen zeros on Tick Tock
and stuff I always like the young one in
the in the group that I kind of came up
with on YouTube because I was 16. I
think I was 17 when I signed my first
contract with uh what they called
Networks I think it was could have been
Channel Flip or no I don't I don't want
to throw them under the bus it might
have been someone else and I remember
trying to get out of the out of the
contract and they were like no you
signed it and it was a terrible contract
it wasn't Channel flip just in case
Channel flip still exists and uh and
then they were like you can't get out
and I was like I'm 17. I'm like okay
you're out can you sign a new contract
I'm like no that's done you had me so
now you lost me what was YouTube like in
in the early days yeah I mean I guess
kind of as I alluded to quite cowboyish
a lot of people trying to get involved
but not really knowing what it was all
about
um for me I literally started my channel
because I wanted to impress the girls in
my class I thought YouTube was like the
coolest thing in the world and uh turns
out it wasn't it wasn't no was this like
that for you or because for me when I
when I started
people just thought I was such a weird
person in my class already yeah I mean
so even even in 2017 when I started
people with the thought I like once it
started to go well yeah so that's when
it changed that's when everyone everyone
wanted to be in a video I wanted to be
in a thumbnail but at the style I was
like Ali put the camera away like Ali
what are you doing like yeah so maybe
the camera out you're supposed to be
seeing a person you know exactly and not
only that it wasn't even the kids in my
class the teacher I had to teach a Drama
teacher you think YouTube's all about
entertaining people should be excited
that you're you know uh you're sharing
some something in yourself and my Drama
teacher I was like this is lame why are
you doing this so wow imagine that is
that rude I know right I feel like drama
teachers and I should hopefully
encourage people doing Tick Tock and
whatever there is out there be real even
maybe uh but yeah back then it was it
was definitely not cool uh but I just
kept going at it because I'm quite uh an
obsessive person and I really enjoyed
the idea of becoming a YouTube partner
so do you know why that's a big deal uh
I do but like our listeners so okay a
YouTube Partner especially back then I
mean now it means you can monetize your
videos but back then I wasn't thinking
about that I was thinking getting a
banner on my YouTube channel which is
you could basically do you remember the
custom banners there used to be no okay
before your time
what was going on there uh so you can
you can get a custom YouTube Banner okay
this is all I wanted you needed like a
thousand subscribers so I thought this
is going to take five days it's gonna be
great
um about two years later still hadn't
hit it eventually got close and then my
friend click on my channel so you could
you could actually get ads on your
channel before Oh actually no okay I
just became partner was very very happy
could get ads on my channel then a
friend in my class clicked my ads like a
thousand times and YouTube thoughts
Casper's trying to make a living by
clicking his own ads and so they banned
my uh my partnership and then I had to
restart and then then when I restarted
that's when things started blowing up
for me when you say you had to restart
the channel restarted yeah that was like
my third Channel [ __ ] yeah completely
from scratch yep and but the good thing
is I think when you restart on YouTube
because when I was when I first started
I I didn't know what I was doing when I
started the second time I started to
figure it out a bit about the third time
I kind of understood how to do this and
uh the secret was going to be
collaborating and so I started
collaborating and I think
it just worked and I feel like uh that
is my advice for people don't ever feel
scared to restart something because
something that at the time was probably
the I was so angry at the guy who did
this to me but now he's like my best
friend because if he didn't do that to
me I wouldn't I wouldn't be where I am
today this reminds me of when when I was
like five years old and I was playing
Pokemon Blue on my Game Boy Pocket and I
got like a hundred and something I
didn't come to South Africa and my and
my and my brother new gamed it and he
deleted the save file and I was like
this was like days and days of work that
I poured into this thing then I started
again and I was like I was actually kind
of glad for it I don't think about the
game one time and you were like way
better or yeah it was way better the
second time around I was like you know I
got Charizard rather than Venusaur so I
think where I'm getting at with this and
what you've probably experienced is like
nothing is a waste of time if you fail
at something you're learning and uh
there's a little bit of inspirational
content for you I love it
we'll put the captions
what sort of stuff were you making in
the early days and relatedly how did you
have the balls to do that when
presumably in school people would have
been like what the hell are you doing
yeah so very early days we don't need to
talk about because it was so weird it
was like me and my bathtub saying like
is this scarier than showering like that
was what I thought content was people
want to see what's scary a bathing or
showering I'm gonna make a whole 10
minute video about this no one could got
about 60 dislikes three likes so then I
was like oh I have to create my own
accounts so I can combat the dislikers
and so I had like 48 cards I don't know
if that's allowed so maybe we'll cut
that we'll cut that out okay
um but but then
but then but then eventually I I started
realizing uh that
maybe I had my own quirks and people
liked my what I did but what they really
wanted to see was me with other people
and so there was this website called
YouNow where you could like live stream
behind other creators okay so it was
basically like a uh like an open mic so
you you stand in line you wait and you
go on live after other creators and
there was this guy called Jacks Gap uh
pointless blog uh Marcus Butler
yeah you don't know who these people are
but these are like the very kind of ogep
YouTubers in the UK they had like at the
time like 10 000 subscribers and I was
like you guys you guys are my biggest
Heroes uh so I I basically went on after
them on you now just said how much I
loved them said I'd love to make videos
with them and eventually they listened
and
um and they said like that's that's chat
I reached out
um I convinced my mom to let me fly to
the UK to meet people I'd met on the
internet uh the age of 17
. this was instead of going on like a
hockey tour so I like gave up this big
hockey tour I was going to go on to do
this everyone at school thought I was
crazy I came over I did what I I think I
do well which is I'm able to kind of
meet people and then meet their friends
and then collaborate with people and and
I built this network and collaborated
with like 10 creators and when I came
back I had I went from like 5 000
subscribers to a hundred thousand
um this was at the time I was finishing
school uh so uh it was it was finally
working and I said I'm gonna take a year
out after school not going to go to
university my parents are like you're
crazy
um so I went I went on on my own way uh
paid paid for it through AdSense lucky
enough it started to work and then yeah
eventually got to start making videos
with some crazy people
um I guess I feel like the the height
was having Ed Sheeran in my bathroom and
me interviewing him okay cool at a time
when like celebrities didn't take
YouTube that seriously yeah and yeah
that's kind of my YouTube story it's all
through collaborating
way in South Africa so yeah I was
originally in South Africa when I
started in a very small town whereabouts
uh do you know knysna no what is but I
know lady Brandon Bloom Fontaine because
I used to live in Lesotho okay lady no
you mean lady Smith I used to call Lady
brand back in the days
I mean it's a small town like a Google
person like uh Joe Rogan or do you just
do it yourself ladybrand is a small
agricultural town in the Free State
programs in South Africa it's a thing
it's 18 kilometers from this area yeah
because I used to live in a city yeah
I've been to Lesotho once or twice it's
freezing up there it's cold in the
winter yeah uh so the student for those
who don't know is it's like a separate
country within South Africa it's a
kingdom yeah and we have two countries
like that we've got Lesotho and
Swaziland uh so what we were either
working there as a doctor or this was
when I was like a child okay um
yeah awesome um yeah we're having our
prescriptions exactly yeah you know yeah
we moved to the UK in 2003. yeah okay
yeah
yeah so you're like a South African
slash the city what do they call them
what what do you say if you say I'm from
the city I am uh basutu oh sorry yeah
okay yeah and the languages okay yeah
nice can you speak it no no no
wait presumably you can speak Afrikaans
then it kind of picky Afrikaans products
that sounds good the only thing I could
remember was like jeans or something
like no sugar added that was on the wait
say it again
yeah I don't I don't even know I wish I
could say that's wrong but I'm so bad at
cards so I'm gonna just accept that as
facts and hopefully someone in the
comments crossed so so you you flew to
the UK at the age of 17 to collab with
YouTubers yeah and I literally got
picked up by Marcus Butler who you know
yeah uh and yeah it was I mean you don't
know Jack's cap no
people in here knows Jack's caption yeah
we're gonna have some so Jack Scott they
are just really cool okay there were
these YouTubers who you can compare them
to like the dimelios okay and they're
gonna hate me saying that but just hear
me out
everyone loves them
they were so cool at the height of their
Fame they were like
we we want to go into something that
they thought was more meaningful they
wanted to get into sustainability they
wanted to get into architecture they
literally walked away from what they
were doing at the very height of what
they were doing which was like insane uh
and like they could have carried on and
on and on and on and had an incredible
YouTube career but they were like no
this is this is not for us and I think
that's quite quite cool why did they
decide it wasn't for them I mean I
haven't I haven't asked them for like
particularly but I I feel like
they they they wanted to do something
else and maybe it wasn't making them
happy yeah and
I
guess
you know I I had a different Journey but
uh at the same time there were the
similarities to that but I definitely
did it for a lot longer and uh and uh
you know kept going whereas they kind of
like no enough is enough but now they're
back on YouTube
yeah Jack's got absolute Legends so okay
so so you started the YouTube channel in
2010 and you're sort of screwing around
making videos channel one channel two
channel three channel three is where it
really starts to take off yeah so the
first two channels the first channel is
called
um dick of Africa okay do you want to
know why why I should probably clarify
that so because my middle name's Richard
okay
uh so the dick yes and then I was from
Africa and I thought like that would be
a good name and uh turns out it wasn't
and then it became decasp
join those together okay
yeah and then the third channel the
third channel was Casper Lee well yeah D
cast which has just became casparated
once I once it became big enough that
you could eventually call YouTube and
you're like can I change the name to
Casper then you're big enough to be able
to call YouTube well yeah you could so
you had like a hotline at that point in
my life there was like you could
communicate with YouTube I'm not sure if
you I'm sure you can today still I
wasn't talking to Suzanne herself yeah
um but yeah you had a partner program a
partner partner manager manager yeah I'm
sure you do yeah I got an email from one
of them there we go you can say change
much well now I don't think it matters
so much but like this is like changing
your URL and it was sick yeah there's a
little button you can press I'm obsessed
with URLs like getting like short
handles things like that
do you have a what's your Like official
URL oh of youtube.com
but my name is not particularly common
so that works out yeah um okay so when
you're 17 you fly to the UK collab with
all these YouTubers that you admired for
a while and you sort of explode to 100
000 subscribers what happens next like
what's the journey what was the journey
like yeah so yeah as I I kind of said it
in the very beginning but you get
reached out too
um and I don't know I just signed the
first person who reached out to me uh so
I signed a contract
uh whereby
um AdSense goes to them and to me so
basically back before YouTube could do
all their own ads they used to get
networks and so there was this whole
industry where networks would convince
Brands to put money before videos and so
they would work with the channels and
with YouTube
um and so yeah I signed a contract that
wasn't great and got out of that because
I was 17. uh and then yeah next thing
was as I kind of alluded to
um deciding do I want to do this full
time I think a lot of creators it's
difficult to make the decision but for
me I was very lucky it really blew up
like it was going very fast and I was at
the right age whereby it was okay to
take a year out and do something that no
one considered a career I mean when I
before I started there I I was talking
about this earlier there was
10 creators I think who are making money
from it there was like
maybe Shane Dawson
um the Shaytards everyone with Shay and
their name basically was making money uh
Ryan uh people like that and Ryan yeah
right here yeah and I just yeah so so
that happened then there was kind of my
I know people say we're OG but they were
the real ogs then I and like that
includes Charlie who's so cool like
I should write a book on YouTube this
would be really interesting about it I
actually went on Mastermind to talk
about YouTube history and I like I came
second so that was great for me
um but yeah then then things you know I
made the decision let's go for this uh
and then yeah how much were you making
back then when you decided this was
full-time legit so yeah good question
um
I suppose in the very beginning I moved
over sorry I decided I'm gonna travel
between like Ireland the US England and
just try collaborate with as many people
as possible at that point I I remember
having four thousand pounds in my bank
account
uh and so that sounds quite hectic
especially now with like with inflation
and stuff but at the time there was
money coming into and and so I felt I
was probably in the very beginning
making like
two and a half three thousand pounds a
month
uh and that was like top 10 YouTubers on
the planet no no no no no no no by that
point there were a lot of YouTubers
doing doing quite well uh but then
things you know over the I'd say kind of
between 2013 and 2016. yeah things got
pretty pretty good in terms of uh
financially
um it's not something we really actually
spoke about at the time I think
you know we I think there are two
reasons one we weren't necessarily doing
YouTube for that but it was a byproduct
um
and two you didn't want to I we weren't
the sort of people who were like oh
we're making all this money we want to
talk about it we want to flex whereas
now I think there are people who also
like to make content about about that
too which is great whereas back then it
just wasn't really a thing so I went
back there like 2013 2016. let's say you
had like a million subscribers how how
much money were these sorts of people
making yeah so not as much as they are
today okay but it was it's less it's
never been on subscribers but yeah you
know if someone's getting 20 million
views a month let's say back then I'd
say depends how they monetize I mean
from AdSense alone
foreign
maybe like 20 000 pounds a month from
the AdSense but I think that would only
make up like 10 you know they could they
could they could make over a million a
year from everything else as well like
merchandise like or to be honest more
like they could do that but like brand
deals were and are still a huge part of
uh part of it then there's also things
like uh deals with uh platforms so new
platforms being created and then YouTube
having to kind of start to con contract
that and pay their own creators to stay
on the platform and do certain things uh
so yeah there was there were tons of
things going on that you could get to a
point where you're making a lot of money
uh and now I've just I mean seeing what
some of these creators are doing like Mr
Beast 50 million Revenue I mean it's
insane
um but yeah it was never you know in the
beginning something we
we thought about but as it progressed
you do start to go oh wow this is this
is a career and and you can't understand
especially when you I was like 1920 and
like people would say what are you doing
uh or my grandmother would be like what
are you doing with your life and you're
like well I'm a YouTuber this is my job
and they're like well what's your real
job uh and and but you would never be
like well look at my bank account it's
actually a job I promise but you would
try and explain to them uh and to be
honest the the time my grandmother
actually
um understood it was a job worth
pursuing was when I met the queen for
the first time and uh and then she's
like okay finally you've uh you've got a
real job you've got a real job now I'm
proud of you just a quick message from
one of our sponsors and we'll get right
back to the episode and this episode is
very kindly brought to you by Heights
Heights is a brain care smart supplement
it is two capsules that you take every
day I've been taking it for the last 12
months and it contains over 20
evidence-based micronutrients that you
need to keep your brain and body healthy
like I said I've been taking Heights
every day for the last 12 months and
through that I've actually become
friends with the founder Dan who we
actually had on season one of this
podcast and this season we also have an
interview with neuroscientist and
psychiatrist Tara swart who is the chief
science officer at Heights as well and
one of the things I love about Heights
is the fact that every single thing they
do is very evidence-based over on their
blog on their website they've got tons
of Articles along with links to all of
the different papers that they've cited
that show all the benefits of the
various micronutrients that they've got
in these two little capsules and the
best thing about taking these is that
it's just two little capsules every
morning so you don't have to deal with
green sludge or any other kind of
faffrey it's just literally taking two
pills it's super easy to sign up you
just go on the website you put in your
address and they send you either a
monthly or a quarterly subscription I
sign up to the quarterly one myself
because a it's cheaper and B I'd have to
take fewer deliveries and if you use the
coupon code Ali 15 at checkout that will
give you 15 off the already discounted
price of the quarterly subscription so
you can try out Heights to your heart's
content so thank you so much Heights for
sponsoring this episode and for helping
improve my own brain care I guess back
in the day from what I've heard from
people who are in or experienced YouTube
back in the day it wasn't even on the
cards that you could make money from the
thing whereas over time like people now
say oh huge oh yeah this is monetization
potential and you get this weird like
incentives whereas I guess you were
doing it for the bands whereas to be
honest even in 2017 I started YouTube
because I saw there was like some kind
of business opportunity here that's
awesome
um I mean yeah I think it went it was
kind of in the very beginning I feel
like creators were kind of Misfits and I
can say that because I'm con you know
putting myself in that in that bucket uh
people who were just kind of Internet
kids
um and then like the next few waves of
creators they became a lot more cool
kids and not only that there were a lot
of really talented people who had
already done something with their lives
and they were like okay YouTube's an
opportunity to to take it to the next
level so you know entrepreneurs or or
musicians or actors they all created
YouTube channels so it also became quite
competitive and not only were you
competing with people
uh you're competing with kind of big
companies like CNN or I mean I don't
know why I've seen that's my big company
on YouTube but every company now has a
YouTube channel and uh all the late
night shows that all have clips and all
that stuff what were some of the
challenges
so I suppose the challenges I mean
to be honest
I think kind of learning that adults
don't always know what's best just
because they're older than you uh so
when you're young you're doing really
well and you don't know why it's kind of
an accident
you really try and look for advice from
other people and I think growing up and
this is something maybe all young people
go through I definitely did uh you you
reach out to people who are older and
they must know the answers and you get
your advice and then you just do what
they say
and that's not always right I mean of
course people who already got to respect
them they usually do have a bit more
experience but you got to speak to the
right people you got to make the right
um calls and that's partly why I do what
I do today is like I've made some
mistakes not like in terms of being
canceled or things like that but more
just things along the way I wish I knew
when I was starting
um things that make things a lot more
efficient uh can help you in terms of
burnouts things like that like like what
just for example like just setting up
how you set up your Affairs as like a
you become a Creator you need to set up
the company how does that work where do
you do that how do you do that
things like how do you set up a system
whereby you don't feel alone as a
Creator how do you create a team who can
help you be consistent with your content
without also taking away from it and
making it to kind of maybe corporate
some creators struggle with that like
the reason they're so successful is
because they're so organic and then but
how do you keep that organic stuff going
while scaling that up so yeah tons of
just there's tons of things and then
just in terms of mental health how do
you kind of stay not grounded but a lot
of creators I've met struggle with
anxiety I think it's a lot of not just
creators but just in general young
people
um and and and having a job whereby
there's not that many boundaries there's
no like uh
off switch or you don't go home and
you're done and you put up your your
feet not saying it's really difficult
all the time but you're kind of always
on and uh I think you know a lot about
that sort of stuff so Keen to get your
thoughts on bandages too well I mean I
think I think the level of what at which
I know is very different uh kind of I I
think the the super interesting thing
um the sort of kind of seeing seeing
your story is that
you were squarely in like the
entertainment category yeah whereas I'm
scrolling the education category and I
feel like it's easier to be in it's way
easier to be in education because you
just teach people stuff and if I need
content I'll read a book and talk about
the book it's like enter how the hell do
you be entertaining for like nine years
in a row and then also like the whole
thing around well you don't yeah I
think the the difficulty of staying
entertaining for a long period of time
plus also like the fact that I think you
developed a very strong
and so Peter the sort of Lifestyle
vloggery type people have the strong
parasocial relationship with the
audience where they genuinely feel as if
they're your friend and will be
disappointed if you do anything bad and
stuff like
and also just the the stratospheric like
growth and things and collabing with all
these people that that's something that
I can't relate to at all because it's
just felt felt pretty chill in my end
because well it's I think that's the
genius of what you do and uh you know
you've you you can create formats a lot
more maybe yeah a lot more than say an
Entertainer and I think
um you know you're when when I do talk
to creators and advise them it's like
how can we come up with some formats
about what you're doing because you
don't want every single time you upload
something the next week you're like
starting from scratch and that's I think
again we we weren't trained we didn't
know how this worked at all it was kind
of accidental uh we don't understand
what that really meant we eventually
started creating formats and and things
evolved
um but yeah I mean I think being a
gaming Creator must be very challenging
but at the same time they get these new
games that come out every now and then
and then they can play those and like
the audience gets excited like GTA 6 is
coming out or whatever and everyone can
jump on that whereas the entertainment
creators are relying on their own
relevancy how can they keep pushing
things and yeah I I definitely very
early on saw that and I think that's
also partly why I wanted to start
building things that I could be like if
people don't care about me in in three
four five years especially when I'm 60
or 70 years old
what am I going to do then uh and so
that's also partly why I launched the
companies I launched this is literally
the stuff I think about on a daily basis
but like you know I've been doing this
for five years now like what does it
look like five years from now when I'm
50 will I still be like what's up guys
welcome back to the channel I mean
you've created infrastructure I love
like that's why I also wanted to
interview people a lot I feel like then
you're not Reliant so much just on you
it's like bringing other people in their
audience enjoys it and being almost a
platform for people rather than it all
being about ali yeah how did you okay so
I've so many questions on this the first
one
um well I haven't done it I didn't do it
well myself but I can try and give you
advice no I mean this is how did you uh
what were the struggles slash Talent
challenges with burnout back in the day
because I guess like the word wasn't
used that often yeah back in like 2010
to 2015. it only really started going
into the sort of people's vocabulary
recently I guess but and I feel like
creators say it a lot and I think people
must be like what the [ __ ] why why are
you sorry if I I don't know if I can
search great yeah
um why are you borrowed time like your
job is to travel the world having fun
and you film it
um and and so I don't think burnout is
by any means exclusive to creators it's
like a universal thing but I think I saw
Grace Beverly talking about this like no
matter how she was on your podcast and
she said this exact thing maybe just put
her video in I don't have to say it but
no matter how much you enjoy uh what
you're doing
um and in the beginning if you do it
enough
uh you start to you start to get burnt
out especially if you push it too much
and you don't take breaks and you don't
have structure
um so I I mean personally I I just kept
pushing through it as long as I could
um and then luckily it got to a point
where where I really felt it
and instead of making like a big deal
out of it or anything because it wasn't
planned I just said to myself take a
break
and that break has has basically let me
hear that break was in 2019
um and I haven't haven't uploaded since
but I suppose what's so lucky is and and
partly planned by me is like I have a
life outside of YouTube that I I can get
up every day and I'm just as excited
about as I was making videos
um so that's also hard and I advise
creators and YouTubers to have lives
outside of their work uh or do workouts
out of YouTube as well that they can do
one day just a quick message from one of
our sponsors and we'll get right back to
the episode and this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
that summarizes books but it's way more
than just book summaries they almost
have a whole study guide for every book
that they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books in lifestyle
and communication basically any genre of
like non-fiction personal development is
self-helpy stuff that will help you
level up your life it's all there on
short form short form Publishers new
book guides and articles every week and
if you're a subscriber then you get to
vote on what book they cover next and in
fact through that system I have voted
for various books that they've then
turned into summaries for example one
book I've recently Revisited on short
form is rework by dhh and Jason fried
who are the founders of Basecamp I've
read rework I think like twice but the
first time already was like absolutely
ages ago and so once I saw that they had
a summary on short form that was really
helpful in allowing me to revisit the
lessons that I learned from the book the
first time around and that's one of the
things I love about short form it's like
I often stumble upon books that I read
like 10 years ago and I'm like oh damn
like I'd actually forgotten most of the
lessons from here but now it's super
easy to revisit those lessons without
having to actually reread the book
anyway if any of that sounds up your
street and you would like to sign up to
the world's best service that summarizes
books then head over to shortform.com
forward slash deep dive and that will
give you a completely free five-day
trial and you can try out the service to
your heart's content that link will also
be in the video description and in the
show notes and thank you so much short
form for sponsoring this episode how did
you maintain consistency over a
nine-year period like there's going to
be times where you just don't feel like
doing a video but you sort of feel like
I probably should because the algorithm
and stuff and like yeah how how did you
deal with that look I I think my videos
were really getting pretty good near the
end
um you know in terms of the beginning
and stuff I was very lucky a lot of
people tuned in because they liked
either me or my friends or the people I
was interviewing
so in terms of consistency
um it wasn't always that consistent but
at that time on YouTube people just
loved it it wasn't as maybe uh difficult
there wasn't as much choice and also
when there's certain hype around people
they can do anything and people might
watch it so there was a bit of that in
the beginning
uh but in terms of uh kind of learning
how to stay consistent I think you know
formats were important I I did
eventually bring in people who could
help uh and and that's like the secret
that's literally my secret to anything I
do in life is find people better than me
and get them to help me do what I do or
or I can help them do what they do and
we can work together
um so yeah and I I do recommend like
also pacing yourselves or pacing
yourself in terms of consistency uh and
just
I think you have to be passionate it's
so hard to do anything if if you're not
enjoying what you're doing and and it
it's like running a marathon even though
it might be a simple thing like editing
a video if you just aren't enjoying it
uh so I think consistency comes when you
follow your passions too but do you
think because there's a lot of people
like I I run this course that helps
people kind of start the YouTube
channels and have accountability and
community and stuff and a lot of them
really struggle with this thing around
like you kind of do have to do it for a
long time before you can expect to see
any kind of results or if if at all and
the thing I always say is like find a
way to make it fun because if you're
doing it for the intrinsic Joy of doing
the thing you're not worried about the
numbers yeah and I find even now to this
day five years on the the less I think
about numbers the happier I am yeah and
I think if you if you do it for the you
know the money which takes it if you
look I think it's hard because on
YouTube we're constantly served big
creators so we see like the you know the
tip of the iceberg so everyone thinks
like that's what you get to but the mid
like 99.9 of people just don't and so if
you're doing it for that you'll
definitely probably quit before you get
there so you've got to do it for
something else and then if that happens
that's great and it's something like Mr
Beast is a great example he just loved
it he talks about this all the time and
uh if if you look at him when he started
imagine anyone being able to look at his
first video on YouTube and seeing him
when he was I don't know at nine years
old being like this is going to be the
kind of the biggest Entertainer in the
world in 2022 you just wouldn't know and
he wouldn't know and so he couldn't like
he could he couldn't have that as a goal
because he probably wouldn't he wouldn't
have made it but he had smaller goals he
like for me like getting partnership was
huge things like that so if you enjoy it
that that really helps what sort of
goals did you have along the way other
than partnership
um I suppose I I wanted to I want I want
to be a talk show host I thought that
was like my idea of Heaven
and then
along the way I realized that I used to
get like massive anxiety every time I
was going to interview someone who I
really looked up to who
I had to kind of
hold the conversation with after the
interview I was usually happy but before
I would spend like five days just just
in utter fear of of what am I going to
ask Ed Sheeran what what am I gonna say
to Kevin Hart's I'm just name dropping
here just just
um but but it wasn't just them it was
the fact like it was like the people
around them all of that stuff and and I
actually realized
as much as I wanted that goal it was it
was uh it was not necessarily for me
yeah
so if you were to
I'd say during
during the journey let's say 20 2010
onwards
um if you were to have sampled your like
contentment like on a scale of 0 to 10
how content are you day to day right now
I guess like over time like what would
that what would the graphic look like
for you I think
in the very beginning like super content
just getting like five subscribers a day
uh and then as things blew up like
like beyond the scale like this is the
comedy this is happening everything so
new everything's so exciting and then
and then actually funny enough even at
like the height of it
I probably felt like I was
achieving less than than I felt when I
was getting five subscribers a day which
is really weird I think partly because
you compare yourself to people around
around you and I was surrounded by other
people's killing it and you're always
like okay
um like how do I get there
um but I think it's also just human
nature you get kind of used used to it
and then the pressure also gets added uh
you know I I think it's natural to look
at 100 comments and you see 99 I think
people say this a thousand times and and
they're all positive but you look at the
one negative and that brings you down
but yeah this is it's by no means a sob
story I I I'd say not my contentment
didn't last to like it was in the very
beginning but it was still great I still
had a great time met amazing people
um but you definitely get used to
whatever it is that you achieve in life
if it's you know if it's money if it's
Fame if it's uh being a rewarded for
your academic achievements
I think you do get used to it and your
happiness can't derive from those things
uh and and if they you know there is a
certain base level whereby it's
definitely difficult if you don't have
say a certain amount of money and and
but once you get past that
doesn't make people happier at all yeah
so it's a great lesson to learn
um well billion I think it would change
yeah I mean most people say that if you
if you take the net worth and multiply
it by three then they'd be happy yeah oh
I just need three times
I've met some very uh
so I've met some billionaires they're
just very unhappy why do you think that
is like every but because loads of
people say this but like oh there's so
many unhappy billionaires but like for
someone for a normal person it's like oh
well it's easy to look at that and think
I think I think again like saying money
whatever it is it kind of accentuates
um whatever your personality is so I
think there's some billionaires who
um are very probably really nice people
and some really famous people a lot of
famous people are really nice people
and it's just made them even nicer
because now they can do it on like a
crazy level
uh but at the same time if you're not
like a happy person I think it can make
it way worse because you maybe you think
oh this is going to finally bring you
happiness and you get there and you're
like oh well this hasn't worked
um and then also everyone's kind of
saying yes to you all the time I'm sure
and that probably adds to to everything
um but yeah it's it's it's it's
fascinating it is kind of it's kind of
scary that a lot of people do spend
their whole lives like after that
and it's hard to like say 100 it doesn't
actually lead to it but I think from
everything everyone's seen in the world
even if you look at you know people in
the public eye and you see what happens
to them when they get there it's it's
not always right yeah it's not always
good yeah did you see any like not that
I've got there by the way I'm talking
about people
like there's a there's almost a Trope
that you see of you know musicians and
stuff that they they get famous and then
suddenly they're on drugs and alcohol
going to rehabit et cetera Etc
um I haven't look at like Ed Sheeran as
someone who has avoided that somehow
yeah um but he had uh he I think he
struggled with anxiety and he's spoken
about that a lot
and and that's kind of extent again that
there's a there's something like it just
it makes whatever you maybe have in your
life a lot more extreme yeah
um in the I guess in the in the world of
creators YouTubers what were the like
what did you see as being like the
downsides of Fame
YouTube is very transparent so everyone
sees exactly how things are going I
think you know in in the old days as an
actor or maybe it's also quite something
with a musician maybe that's why they
get so stressed but like everyone can
see exactly how you're doing on YouTube
Every time so you're only as kind of
good as your last video and I think no
matter what people say and they're like
I don't care like how it's going or
whatever they look at that and they're
like [ __ ] that video is not got 10
million views in a day I wanted 12.
which is so weird because you're like 10
million views is great yeah
yeah I think you see that at every every
level of the thing and this is why I
often like I find that
you know the numbers wax and Wayne when
you see the analytics just in front of
you every single day it's just like
that's true last videos was eight out of
ten on the analytics card next one
really needs to be good oh [ __ ] the next
one's not good 100 Beginning of the End
like I'm irrelevant now No One's Gonna
care were you having those sorts of
thoughts yeah the problem is when when
you allow the good to make you feel
happy you're allow the bad to make you
feel sad and so you've got to almost
avoid getting too excited when things
are going well with certain things
because you've got to try and find that
happiness outside like I've got this
most incredible girlfriend Amber and uh
we've been together for five years now
and
you know I'm currently going through uh
you know many things with my businesses
good bad loads of great things
and sometimes there's there's difficult
days and like going home and not and
just kind of switching off and getting
my happiness from just hanging out with
her is a lot healthier and and it it
makes me feel like hopefully when things
don't go so well because that's bound to
happen
that hopefully that won't affect me as
much as if as long as I don't know the
really good stuff make me super happy
not not saying
don't take any happiness from it but
don't rely on it for for your happiness
yeah in 2017 you talked about you made a
video talking about your experience with
having Tourette's yeah
for people who might not have heard
about it and like like what is
Tourette's and how did that affect your
life yeah so
um Tourette's I think in the mainstream
media is people
who swear a lot and they just can't
control it and they say like really
inappropriate things or people who do
like loads of things with their arms
which is kind of physical ticks uh or
and I kind of I struggled a little bit
with both but less swearing I used to
whistle
used to Bob my head like that is to
click my leg
um actually one time we were on Safari
in South Africa and there was an
elephant and our our car broke down kind
of like it wouldn't start the we
couldn't start the engine it was and it
was looking at us and it was going like
with its ears you know and that's when
this that's when they hate you yeah
um and and then I just I just had to
make this monkey noise like oh it sounds
ridiculous but like I screeched and that
was kind of one of the first times my
parents were like okay [ __ ] like I think
I was like six at the time
and then I this is he can't control
these things we researched it there
wasn't that much out about it at the
time
um and yeah eventually got on lots of
medication some of the medication
actually led to horrible allergic
reactions
um
but yeah it got really bad around 12
years old just got obviously it's
something quite easy to bully someone
about so it got a bit bullied
um teachers would kind of kick me out of
class if they didn't really understand
it which sounds crazy because we
explained it to them but maybe they
thought I was still taking the piss
um
and yeah it was it was it was tough but
what made it better was when I was when
I was ever when I was focusing on
something so if I was playing tennis or
if I was playing computer games or if I
was making YouTube videos
um or even now like I'm focusing
um it always improved and and so I think
that's partly why I got so obsessed with
well maybe lots of people in South
Africa were out there uh hanging out
with their friends and so on maybe I was
more obsessed in what I was doing
because it was an escape
uh so yeah but now I think around 50 I
don't know what the stat is but a lot of
people with Tourette's when they're
younger uh when they get older it gets a
lot better
um and and someone one of those lucky
ones who it hasn't gotten worse it's
kind of gotten a lot better for me uh
but yeah
wow that's a
how how was it kind of making a video
about it talking about the experience
so interestingly
it was never kind of a big part of what
I did but I realized that there were
going to be a percentage of my followers
who had Tourette's and there was nothing
better than when I when I heard that the
uh the US football goalkeeper had
Tourette's I don't even know his name
it's not a big deal to me but just
hearing of someone's kind of successful
having Tourette's made me feel really
good so I was like okay maybe there'll
be someone in my audience who can listen
to this so I made a video about it
um and yeah people reacted really well
I'm sure there were some some comments
but that was the time when I looked at
the positive comments and I was like
that's great
and yeah it's something it's something
I'm actually proud of
um that I that I went through because I
think it's important to have challenges
in life and uh yeah that's something I
had as a challenge
you um I read somewhere that you had you
worked into like mindfulness and
meditation and like what was your
journey with those things so
my mom used to do it and she used to try
to get me to meditate when I had
Tourette's and that didn't work so
um many years later uh this is actually
during lockdown so I had this crazy
experience where
I didn't see people very much and and
then when I did for some reason I was
getting so socially anxious
and it could be something like sitting
in the car with a really good friend
like my best friend I could be in the
car with him
and I could basically have a panic
attack
and it really came out of nowhere and
I'm not sure if it's related to just
stress at the time or
I still don't know why it happened but I
I sought out therapy and uh you know we
worked through it but one of the things
the guy recommended was to meditate and
so I downloaded the Calm app and uh I I
I learned about
experiencing feelings in my body and
thoughts and kind of noticing them for
what they are and not taking them as
seriously as I used to but yeah it that
said it was still it doesn't just fix it
it's not one of those things I think
some people think like if I meditate 10
times this week everything's gonna be
good you still have there's still other
factors at play but over time it's
definitely kind of helped
um alongside
just doing things again and doing things
that I'm uncomfortable with I'm
comfortable with so yeah like for
example podcasts yeah
um
you know I'm not asked on that many
podcasts but I've been asked on probably
10 podcasts this year
and I've said no to every single one
and
because I was like What if I have a
panic attack while I'm doing a podcast
which is you'd probably look at me now
and you're like you probably don't seem
like that
um
but but yeah so I was avoiding it and
then I was like I got the DM from you
and I'm already getting a lot better
like the last kind of year and a half
I've just been trying to do things that
make me scared and I was like okay this
is a great opportunity he seems like a
really nice guy this is not going to be
intimidating and now I'm gonna do it and
even before this I'm obviously I was
pretty nervous
um but
but now I've done it I'm gonna probably
do more and so that's also my advice is
one is meditating
but two if something really scares you
obviously don't jump right into the deep
end but try and do it because it's way
worse in your head
uh especially things like sitting in the
car with my friend I mean there's
nothing dangerous about that but
something about that was was giving me
anxiety and you didn't have anxiety
before this
um not so much no no but but I think it
is related Tourette's I mean Tourette's
add bit of OCD all of these things are
kind of related uh so yeah you know uh
it's something it's something my you
know my mom struggled with my sister
struggles with so
yeah but I think you know again it's one
of those things which at the time it's
it sucks and and so on but if you can
use it to teach yourself lessons and
also appreciate when you're not feeling
anxious and you're just like wow I feel
normal
um and then you just enjoy simple things
then then it's actually a bit of a power
too what what does your meditation
practice look like
so
it's it's super competitive the opposite
of what meditation should be I uh no I I
basically sit down
um
and and listen to to calm what's her
name on calm is this one Teresa is the
name Teresa or something everyone people
in the comments will know who I'm
talking about uh and she basically does
a guided meditation and I do that
um but sometimes even even before I'm
doing something that's difficult I'll
just take some time to breathe I'll no
matter what happens I'll feel nervous
like I can't stop that and but I'll
notice what that is and I'll be like
okay
what's the worst that can happen
you can end up in hospital
what's the word that can happen you
could die okay that sucks I'm surprising
here
okay that's that's what you usually goes
to my friend
and then
I just feel like you just you
you
breathe
you can even get things like this which
you might think why do I have this and
when I first met yeah we shook hands
that I had in my head you probably don't
remember yeah but this is like it's just
like something I can play with it
distracts me
things like that you just come up with
your own like come up with your own
stories of things that work for you
maybe going for a run for example in the
morning could also help a kind of really
stress things like that
um makes life part fun
coming up with ways to get through
things and then the best thing is once
you finally do something you're really
nervous about or you struggled with in
the past and you actually do it there's
no better feeling like after this
podcast I'm just gonna go home being
like yeah I did it battled through
exactly
yeah so this is something I've been I've
been looking into a fair bit I mean
firstly thank you for being so open this
is great like um I'm sure there are
people listening to this whoever well
that's really originating with all of
the things you're saying and like oh my
God thank God someone's talking about
this well I saw I think so Lewis Capaldi
recently talked about this I was like
that's that makes me feel good look it's
not just me so yeah because you're
seeing him struggle makes me feel great
yeah especially with a lot of a lot of
the mental health stuff as well like
it's it's so easy to think that this is
just the way I am this is normal and
that no one else has has those struggles
but hearing kind of people like you
being open about it on podcasts it's
just like super nice and yeah thank you
I've been
doing a bunch of research for the book
that I'm writing around
um like uh energy yeah and and like uh
sympathetic versus parasympathetic
nervous system
um I'll pretend I know what those mean
sympathetic nervous system in a way when
you're in sort of stress mode when
you're outside yeah and you literally
you know this stuff well can you give me
a session yeah we'll give it a go
um but there's it's sort of even people
who say that they don't who who wouldn't
identify with struggling with anxiety
there's some stat that like 75 of the
workforce in at least in the US feels
that sort of sympathetic activation in
that sort of stress anxious mode while
they're at work
and you know there's a lot of stuff
around how evolutionarily it made sense
that you know there was a bit of a
threat in the grass and now you want to
be in fight-or-flight mode because you
might have to run away from a tiger but
you know having a conversation with your
boss at work or being in the car with
your friend like you wear the the brain
tricks us into being in reactive flight
fight or flight mode
and really there's like so much science
around just like deep breathing like you
know short took it sympathetic mode
activates parasympathetics which is like
rest and recharge mode
and retraining again I'm not going to
know the words that you know like
retraining those those things in your
brain that kind of
every time at that point when I didn't
want to get in the car I was like every
time I go to a car it just happened
and
you just gotta slowly learn how to deal
with it and eventually you can retrain
your mind not to have that feeling and
so that's why you know people who who
get to where they get to it it's from
practice they don't not everyone starts
off super confident and uh and and able
to do everything it takes time and
that's why I love hearing people like
Lewis Capaldi or whoever it is saying
like how difficult it was yeah
yeah so
2019 you upload your last YouTube video
you decide that you're going to take a
break which means like I'm quitting
YouTube videos
I'm back maybe
why did you take that extended break and
why did it extend for so long
so
it was also around the time things were
kind of going into lockdown so I was
taking I think around if I remember
correct I took like a few months break
the businesses also that I'm involved in
so I've got a few things that I do
outside of YouTube and they were really
starting to take up a lot of time
and I at the same time I wasn't enjoying
what I was doing as much I don't think
my audience was even enjoying what I was
doing that much of the time this wasn't
this feeling of like uh momentum
and and so I I just I just
just didn't think about it too much
without gonna take a few weeks and that
that turned into years and now I'm
loving what I'm doing and and so I
suppose to be a YouTuber now
um
you really have to it has to be a big
priority and it has to kind of almost be
a full-time job unless you have a great
team
uh so I and I wasn't prepared to to do
that because I needed to also focus on
on my other Ventures
yeah so when you say momentum and you
felt the audience wasn't enjoying it
like what were those signs what was that
like so I mean yeah it's just I feel
like
you know views aren't at the same place
as they were when you were when you're
on your way up uh but yeah also
struggling with ideas struggling just to
be like I want to make this video I I
think YouTube it went also from a place
whereby
if you had a certain amount of
subscribers those subscribers would see
your content to being about how much
time was your audience watching your
video so the watch time became super
important
um and yeah that was that was it's
difficult it's difficult to keep going
especially as we spoke about earlier in
terms of entertainment and YouTube and
yeah I just I just I just saw it as a
great opportunity to to to focus on what
I was doing and not also I didn't want
to stay on YouTube as long as I possibly
could and just wait I wanted to be like
this was a great chapter in my life I
really enjoyed it it went really well
and now I'm doing this
so what was the what was the um story
behind the first the first I can
offshoot business yeah so so my one of
my companies is called influencer.com
uh that's a good domain thank you thank
you yeah I mean so my co-founder
actually got it yeah it's like a house
um but it's it's definitely helpful
um so essentially at the time uh my
co-founder was like uh he was about 20
years old he was friends with my
girlfriend at the time and he asked her
if he could meet with me
um and and and we met and uh and I spent
like three hours with him just at
firstly what you said I was so impressed
by the domain uh and and then he kind of
told me about his dream of of helping
creators
um work with brands at scale and and I
just thought the one big problem right
now with the space is that creators are
working with Brands they don't really
like to work with
uh and there's not much choice for
creators
and and so I was like this is a great
opportunity for
for creators to be able to make a living
from what they do and choose the right
Brands to work with and hopefully Their
audience will see that too and then
they'll be happy for the Creator
uh so yeah that's how we kind of got
going the vision was to build meaningful
relationships between Brands creators
and their audiences and at the time it
was just the two of us uh since then
we've we've scaled the team uh to five
countries we've got 93 people there
um and yeah we've we've worked with
amazing Brands amazing agencies and yeah
just so proud of the culture we've built
there and the leadership team
um yes it's been a great experience
what's what's your role so I'm I'm Chief
Visionary officer and co-founder so I
get really involved
in a number of areas firstly I am Ben's
shoulder to cryon who's our CEO
everything that happens he comes to me
and we talk about it that's really great
when you have a business where you have
a co-founder that you're so open with
um essentially I I help guide the
product you know what creators want
because I speak to a lot of creators I
was a Creator
um then also working with the brands and
helping guide their creative strategy
so what what kind of content works on
different platforms and not only on
different platforms what kind of content
works on the features within those
platforms
it sounds quite obvious but when you're
working with a brand who says we want to
work with 300 creators and we want to
create this campaign and it needs to hit
this this and this and then all the
different creators within that have
their own Styles their own objectives
and you kind of have to bring that all
together that's when you need a company
that not only has incredible uh people
working there who understand the space
but also the technology which connects
everything together so for example pulls
in information from the apis to share
with the brand making sure it's all
legitimate and it's not screenshots
um that's what we've built at influencer
that's that's super exciting so what is
what is the product because I think I
last looked at it in 2018 or 2019
something like that where I was I was
like oh I can work with Starbucks and
then it was like oh but your end is like
oh you connect your
very solid on board I was like wow thank
you yeah yeah and it's to be honest we
we did a focus on creators for the first
kind of four or five years as much as
I'd like to in terms of the product
because because we needed to get the
brands on board so we needed to build
great products for them so that they
would spend more money with our creators
uh but now we're able to to focus on the
creators a lot more when it comes to
products so we have waves for
advertisers
which essentially allows the the brands
to log on
choose the creators they want to work
with once that happens
um they're able to kind of kind of guide
the content exactly how it's going to
look how it's going to feel approve it
and then also receive all the analytics
afterwards so it's kind of like you know
what Trello board looks like so it's
like kind of like a Trello board but
within each within each layer the the
the stats are being pulled in directly
from the apis so it's all in one place
it allows
again people might not realize but like
influencer marketing there's so many
stages to it you know you might have a
brand
then you have an agency
then you have us sometimes who comes in
then you have a manager and then you
have a talent so you've got five
stakeholders all wanting to approve a
piece of content
and so it's very difficult when you're
doing that with 300 creators with five
of those people yeah and so basically
the product does that for them and and
for for creators we've got uh waves for
creators now which is coming out
um on app right now right now it's web
app but now it's coming out on iPhone
and Android and it's essentially allows
creators to build media kits uh that
pulls in the information automatically
that's handy so you can have one link
you share with everyone you have to
screenshot little things and update the
stats exactly and then obviously it's
also going to allow you to work with
Brands and be discoverable
um and yeah it's very very exciting but
it is it is different I suppose a lot of
creators
um
I speak to build consumer-facing
businesses which they could come on your
podcast and they can be like
there's my product come and buy it and
and I kind of always wanted to do B2B
stuff
and I I think it's because I was I maybe
struggled I'm not good at selling to my
own audience I know what you mean it's
really hard selling to individuals
exactly businesses want to spend money
to make money like exactly and and only
and also it's kind of more unique as a
Creator in that space because only 10 I
think of creative businesses are are B2B
whereas the rest are consumer yeah yeah
it was kind of a good spot for me to go
and see it's really solid like I've been
speaking to a few people who've um on
the podcast recently who have had like
big multi tens of millions of dollars
exits yeah
um from B2B companies B2B marketing
thingies that have a bit of a technology
underlay it seems like you guys have
strong technology exactly the underlying
Foundation no business is very valuable
because it's not tied to you as an
individual in your own personal
relevancy exactly like very
non-stressable exactly exactly what I
wanted to try and do and uh yeah no it's
been great and then
um we also I also have margarine with
Joe Sugg so margarine's a management
company that we started with you know
WME IMG yeah I've heard of those the big
like agency yeah they're like they
represent people uh like uh Jessica Alba
yeah I don't know why that's the one
celebrity that comes to my mind
um but we convinced them to launch a
management company with us that
basically could help our talent when it
comes to both the digital careers but
also the more traditional stuff so it's
kind of bringing those two things
together
and the reason I love that is because I
get to work with like creators who are
starting out today and try and act like
a grandfather and be like back in my day
it was like this and this is what I did
these are the mistakes I made
um and then we've built a great team
there too so we've we actually just
opened an office in La last week uh so
yeah it's it's been it's been really fun
what is what does a day in your life
look like a week in your life yeah so
because I'm working across multiple
things there's two other things we
haven't mentioned yet actually okay so
for contact one of those one of the two
other things and then we can yeah so
we've got proper living I mean I just
this is why it's embarrassing when
people say what do you do and then I try
and go into like this speech I'm like
people are probably thinking you're just
some guy from La who thinks he does all
these things but um but basically I got
another thing called proper living uh
which is the student accommodation
business an excuse for me to go back to
South Africa and so we have like 200.0
English so those are the days and that
actually is consumer yeah however
funny enough we're also selling to
buildings so we want them to use our
brand so that we then consult how the
hell did you start a brilliant student
property rental business yeah so so yeah
entertainment YouTuber to student Pro
like it's a big real estate Muggles
what's going on there yeah so
essentially it was an opportunity
brought to me as an investment so they
said do you want to invest in this
property it's going to be a student
accommodation business
and I said like that's cool like maybe
I'll do it but
I I it struck me that
um student accommodation in South Africa
at least I'm sure it's like this
internationally too but it had terrible
social media it had terrible marketing
it had terrible branding
and so I thought okay I'll invest the
money but I also want to basically start
a company where whereby we build a brand
and then going forward when you build
buildings you use my brand and and and
and we go like that so yeah we built
this really cool brand we we started
with a building with 90 rooms we've got
now a third building this year so we'll
be over 200 and we have a waiting list
of like 1.5 K students in Cape Town
which which is crazy because
um there's not actually just in Cape
Town yeah but at the same time what's
great about it is 1.5 K is not a lot of
people
in terms of like a consumer products no
but when it comes to accommodation it's
very meaningful it's like for buildings
with so so that's that's what's quite
fun is like we've we've seen this kind
of this product that is is is usually
you know it's a it's kind of a big
ticket item for someone but it wasn't
being sold correctly it's two people so
what's the idea so what do you what do
you do with this with those companies so
with proper living or yeah yeah with
proper living it's a proper living we're
just scaling over the next like 30 years
what do you personally do I'm I'm the
founder uh a co-founder and uh on the
board and basically I just help help run
it but with proper living we have a
great management team I'm I'm not kind
of like uh day to day on the ground
trying to check people into their rooms
but that's also something I've again to
do all of these things it sounds a bit
crazy and you're like how do you why do
you do all of these things it's really
the teams I've put together all the
teams that have come together and then
they've wanted me to be involved and
then I really let them like do what they
do which is like operate yeah and I'm
there to really just help elevate
that sounded very cringy but I mean
everyone doesn't know I've I'm loving
this like this is like kind of if we
think of what does the evolution of a
Creator look like it's like you've got
you know starting off doing all the
YouTube videos yourself doing your own
editing and stuff then you've got sort
of the next level where you build a
little bit of a team around you like
I've got my editor I've got my thumbnail
guy I never did that like I said that
but you skip you skipped that step and
then it's always like all right cool now
I need to build products and [ __ ] within
the own ecosystem so you try and sell
stuff to your own audience and then it's
like oh crap this is all still based on
my own relevancy therefore let me build
a brand like James Hoffman's physical
goods company let me build a brand that
is not within but that's not tied to my
own relevancy but I can just be the
marketing driver or the marketing
director for for the said brand
and it's like you've sort of gone to
sort of two levels up which is even
we're just like okay cool let's build a
brand let me be the the co-founder or
maybe the owner and we'll get another
team to operate it
and then it's like sort of the next
level up from that it's like I'm gonna
be a board member and co-founder of
multiple things hire a CEO and like a
management team to run all of them so
that I get to do the fun Visionary type
marketing type stuff and other people
get to do the boring day-to-day
management stuff I wish it was all
planned but it just kind of as things go
and develop over time you I suppose you
get a Leverage
either is it money that you could invest
into something or have you got a ton of
you have a network that you could
introduce people to
um and yeah you just find great people
you make sure that they really are
passionate about what they're doing uh
but yeah I've been super fortunate I
mean the these the the people running
these companies are like the heroes so
I'm just like the lucky guy so so we've
got influencer we've got the management
we've got proper living what's okay on
the portfolio this is this is super
exciting
an exclusive for you
we're doing water no I'm joking sorry
that's not that speaking off uh but uh
no so I have a I've got a fund as well
now uh that I'm a partner in
um sounds fancy what is it fun so it's
called create event what is the fund and
what is that what is it what is the
funding so there's many different types
of funds uh this is a venture capital
fund
uh so we invest in early States early
stage startups we take kind of a small
ticket size usually like one percent of
the business
um and we help we help the entrepreneurs
between seed and series a okay uh
sometimes we have done a b before a
series B and basically these are just
different stages in companies uh in kind
of their their raising Capital careers
raising Capital careers in the in their
growth Journeys and uh yeah I mean right
now kind of the the titles are being a
bit blurred with some people like
they're changing like they're saying
we're doing a pre-seed a pre-pre-precede
all these things but usually yeah yeah
usually the business we invest in are
worth kind of between you know 12
million
to 50 million and uh we we try and you
know get get not a not a big amount we
don't come in there as a lead but we
invest how did you set this up was this
a thing someone came to you and was like
Casper mate you should be a partner in
this beauty fund so yeah so essentially
um
early on uh when I started influencer
other entrepreneurs started to come to
me and and basically say would you like
to be an investor they like the idea I
think of having
um a Creator on their cap table someone
who could talk about the the company uh
and I think they also like the idea that
I also had my own kind of business and
and maybe there are some experiences
which I could share with them
um and so I've got a genius partner not
called Sasha coletsky and uh at the time
he was at Harvard Business School being
really smart he was like top like one
percent of everything he ever did
uh and and he's and I kind of I I said
to him is this a good investment because
I wasn't an investor I didn't know what
what a good investment looked like
especially in venture capital
which is a very unique asset class and
and he saw some of them and he was like
that's not good that's not good oh whoa
that is good actually can I invest in
that with you
and we went to the we went to the the
founders and they're like yeah you can
invest with Casper
and and so he kind of realized that as
just a very smart guy
that the founders weren't that
interested in having him just invest
because they could get especially the
best companies in the world they can get
money from anywhere but but what the
founders wanted uh was was creators on
their cap table uh and then celebrities
musicians people that they could talk
about or could talk about their products
Ashton Kutcher exactly people like that
exactly so so then Sasha was like what
about if uh what about if we put
together a collective of creators and we
all start investing together so
essentially we invested in about uh kind
of seven companies uh with YouTubers
musicians actors and we just bring them
deals and we would invest
uh and then Sasha my partner he would he
would invest his own money so he was
just making money by being able to come
into these uh really good Investments
and that did really well there were some
great paper returns it was a good time
but then we also had an accident a
company called faceit uh which is a
gaming platform uh and and that sold it
merged with another company but then
eventually it was 1.5 billion dollars it
sold for and so yeah we had we had we
kind of yeah we returned our fund yeah
um well not our fund at the time it was
just a group of us investing but we
returned all the money with the seven
companies one of them returned the fund
or one of them returned all the
Investments yeah sick it was great so
now everything else everything's still
going there's some really good uh
they're absolutely killing it yeah
um but like within three years you don't
really expect yeah I mean it's more like
a funny penny at a time exactly isn't it
um but but then people saw that and uh
and Sasha was working at a company
called Bridgepoint which is like a huge
private Equity Firm they've got like 30
billion under assets or something and
um and he he told them he wanted to set
up a fund and we we we we set it up and
they and some of the top guys there
invested
um and yeah we we set out to raise like
10 million uh dollars or something like
that uh we raised 20 million dollars
um and now we get to invest in some
incredible consumer internet startups
um around the world alongside incredible
creators and uh yeah it's it's it's very
fun
why why are you doing all this why not
why don't put your feet up because we
have a good time with Amber like live
the live the chill life it's uh it's
just to be honest like working with with
good people I really enjoy I think when
we go back to what I said about those
businesses I was I am involved in
I am operationally involved but
but I I do see myself as a as an
investor like I love I love to do loads
of things I don't like having all my
eggs in a single basket and and so I I
think like investing in stuff is great
because I can I can help them in terms
of giving them advice as an entrepreneur
but also kind of navigate this social
media space and a lot of these companies
now
um they they take social media very
seriously that's how a lot of them grow
uh as you know and um and so yeah I feel
like I can provide value I like to wake
up every day and have a challenge it's
it's just good fun and uh you know we're
just getting started I'm still in my in
my 20s yeah so let's see so no not time
to uh I guess retire yet
because something okay so uh I've had a
few Chats on this pod in in the last few
days where I've had this idea floating
in my mind of hey this seems kind of
cool working with businesses and stuff
and I think oh I'm only 28 why would
anyone listen to me and I was like
freaking like you're literally doing the
thing that's like at the Pinnacle of
kind of the evolution of Creator economy
well um I I think it it's like
it's again it's the people I'm who I'm
working with I'm somehow getting very
lucky with getting them to to wanting to
to do stuff with me and so like for
example the fund
without Sasha it doesn't exist but I'm
hopefully providing him with something
where he can also say the same thing and
so that's what a really good partnership
feels like
um so yeah I feel like
you've it goes back maybe to the really
start of my career on YouTube was I
couldn't convince people to collaborate
with me when I had
20 subscribers I couldn't convince
people with like 10 000 subscribers to
collaborate with me then when I got to
10 000 subscribers I could do stuff with
them when I got to whatever I got to you
can start to do stuff with people and so
what I recommend is just really
collaborate with as many people as you
can and don't just say on day one I'm
gonna reach out to Elon Musk and ask him
to invest in my company
build up slowly get people who are doing
stuff and as you build up and you get
more and more people to help you you
eventually get more and more leverage
and then eventually somehow you're doing
cool [ __ ] and people people kind of
think you just got there overnight but
there's like years and years of work
that went into that I guess it's worth
bearing in mind you started in like 2010
so like you've been here yeah but you're
I mean you're killing it I've seen I've
seen how many people are downloading uh
your courses yeah but like you know view
to subscriber ratio is going down will
that be relevant three years from now
all of that [ __ ] you know but that's the
thing I feel like there's there's just
such an opportunity for anyone who
understands the space like you do New
Media
there's just so many things you can do
and it doesn't just have to be your
stuff it can be helping for example do
you know Josh Peters he he does like
pranks trust me doesn't actually
managers yeah so he's like my best
friend I don't know uh we actually live
together still
and uh he he does these incredible
YouTube videos
but he also realizes like that's great
but he can also help he can create his
own advertising company like he can help
other brands that kind of share his
vision and are quite cheeky he can help
them create incredible content and so
now he's doing that as well and so I
really I guess if there are any creators
listening I'm gonna create a bit of
competition for myself which I probably
shouldn't but like don't just look at
creating consumer products look at look
at the B2B space to help help do some
stuff there and and get everyone on the
same wavelength because a lot of Brands
out there don't know what they're doing
and uh we gotta help them what what
drives you these days what drives me
presumably it's not making more money
presumably but like I mean there's
always like a bit of a part of it
eventually investors are always like oh
in fact but like really come on
um what drives me
I suppose it's it's it's going back to
doing little challenges trying to do
things I'm scared of because I get like
a huge rush once I've done it yeah uh
but yeah I I kind of it's like doing
cool [ __ ] yeah doing cool [ __ ] just
enjoying love I don't I I kind of just
every day I I look at my calendar and
it's it's kind of made up of a little
bit of influence a little bit of
Margaret being a little bit of creative
Ventures and so on and it's so fun to
like get to meet all these people right
now I also enjoy
um kind of uh mentoring some people in
my company who maybe this could be their
first job uh and things like that and
just going to speak to them and seeing
what they're doing that kind of stuff I
know that's that's what you have to say
when you you're on a podcast what else
inspires me
um I don't know I guess challenge
without that's I think a lot of I've
spoken to someone who actually and
you've spoken to many of these people
who've sold
um a business maybe they've built up and
they've like thought the day that they
sell their business will be the happiest
day of their life and it's a very happy
day but what happens is like a week or
two later
it's not like itching and going what's
my meaning like I don't want to just go
and play golf for the rest of my life
and they realize like that humans are
built to have challenges it's like when
you play The Sims on cheat mode
right am I right what was the cheat mode
on The Sims
I can't remember
the word it was like unlimited I used to
play SimCity yeah do you ever play on
cheat I oh yeah was that more fun or
less fun than it was it was always fun
for a bit to get to Taipei 101 let's
shove that Twin Towers let's put them in
the town let's get Empire State Building
put it over there all right I'm bored
now yeah exactly so if I if I take them
seriously I would have understood I'm
definitely not playing life on cheat
mode yeah it's still yeah
still some zeros to go still some time
to go let's say I don't know let's say
you had 100 million in the bank uh what
would there be any
difference between your calendar in that
hypothetical and now
probably not no nice that's a good place
to be yeah yeah
yeah because that's that was like three
weeks ago
so now it's gone down to what like 84.
I think
oh
in life I think no it's I just enjoy it
I I really do yeah
what would you would you change things
so the only thing I would change is I
probably wouldn't sell courses anymore I
just check them on YouTube for free I
think that's that I think courses are
the only thing that I do that actually
but that's about scheduling make money
uh you didn't no it's not scheduling but
in terms of okay if you're gonna go like
that yeah yeah uh yeah I think there's a
lot more things I could do to help other
people that I'd love to do definitely
um in what way do you want to help other
people like do you have an idea of what
sort of service you want to offer to the
world as cringe as that sounds but I do
think it will involve South Africa
um I think it's it's going through a
very difficult time uh and and there's
just there's just unlimited things you
could do there to try and make a
difference so I I would like to set up
an NGO in um in South Africa one day
around young people around education
education there's it's just it's not
where it should be uh like many places
um and so even as someone who never went
to University myself I just see the
power of going to school of learning you
know being safe at school uh having a
meal all those things like I'm so lucky
you you know to to have grown up in a
home where like I could get a camera
things like that there's so many things
I had in my life that if I didn't have I
would have had no chance I just want to
try and give that to a few more people
one day okay so
um if you
I guess you've been in this in this sort
of online world now for for a very long
time and we have you know a bunch of
kind of young entrepreneurs and actually
a lot of older people who want to become
entrepreneurs listening to this who love
the idea of either uh they who who love
the idea of being able to
uh do what they love and make a living
from what they love whether that's the
Creator world or the business world or
the freelancer world or anything like
that
do you have any general top tips things
that you've learned over this big
question but like the things you've
learned of these last 12 years that you
think have a look at my answers here
um yeah top 10 tips no
um
this is my my thing is
it's not
about how hard you work it's about how
smart you work so if if you're just
spending tons of time on something that
doesn't mean it's gonna reap rewards
it's not always the right thing to be
doing so be prepared to
not only obviously I'm not saying don't
work hard but but work smart be prepared
to walk away from things that aren't
actually gonna work
but that said you could also work away
from the next [ __ ] Facebook so yeah I
caveat all my answers with like I'm like
a contrarian to myself
um then just just again surround
yourself with with people that you
aspire to be more like so it's a pretty
common thing that people say but like
The Five People You spend most of your
time with become the person you are or
you become the person yeah
um so surround yourself with people like
that uh
you know know your value you are
everyone's good at something and when
you know your value
sell yourself when you meet people try
your best obviously don't just go in
there
um and brag about yourself but be
confident and remind people why it's
important that you're around and you're
involved
um like for me I think my angle is a
Creator who hopefully understands
business and so I always remind people
of that and try and make sure like
everyone knows this is what they can
come to me for and then when they think
of something maybe they think oh I need
someone to come to a panel oh him
because I I make it very clear what what
I can add
um
I I suppose me to meeting people I I
spoke you know I spoke about our fund
earlier we don't meet everyone but we
try and meet as many entrepreneurs as we
can just because
even if it's not the perfect business
for us to invest in because we're
probably only investing like one percent
of the deals we do I mean the deals we
look at uh but but we want to meet
everyone
have a conversation learn something from
them they can hopefully learn something
from us and they can walk away with a
good experience because you never know
where those people are going to end up
and like there are a lot of people out
there who only give time of day to
people who they think they can get
something from now and I think that is
like
I think that's a short-term uh it makes
sense but long term that it's actually
really stupid and when I say it makes
sense it's just it's a shitty way to be
but you can see why people think uh why
would I spend time with this person
don't be like that's just so so silly
because everyone has something to add
now and also you never know where
they're going to be
um so those are a few tips I mean
yeah I don't know if you have anything
out to add but I don't know I mean
honestly I was I was surprised that you
said yes to the podcast because I was
thinking that oh yeah he's a bit of a
long shot Casper he's a big deal um
there we go that's kind of cool I mean
yeah yeah it just as I said I I don't uh
look I don't get asked to go on every
podcast in the world but I also I I
haven't been on a podcast probably in a
very long time big fan of what you do so
um yeah do you ever struggle with
procrastination yes what do you do about
it
oh not great
um I think okay here we go the answer is
to make sure someone else is going to be
disappointed if you don't do it so like
I'm a people pleaser so for example I
don't have a PT but let's just say I had
a PT uh and I wanted to get really
strong in the gym
I would go to the gym not to disappoint
that person yeah I've got my PT session
at seven today there you go and you
don't want to disappoint the words if
it's just me and my Slidell I'm gonna
like just come up with an excuse yeah uh
so when it comes to like waking up early
if if I want to wake up early and I'm
like I procrast I don't like doing that
I'll set something really early that I
have to go to and then I'll do it I love
doing that too like a sort of the the
atam breakfast
you hate yourself you hate yourself for
it but you have to then you're there
you've got the coffee it's like okay I'm
glad I woke up for this so just being
around other people doing stuff with
other people uh I think I think that's
why it creates is also struggle a lot of
them work in silos and when they don't
have a team it's really hard because
you're procrastinating there's no one
else kind of uh kind of there to take
account for what you're doing hmm so I
think that helps yeah what's but I'm
Again by no means uh good at that I'm a
procrastinator what do you do when
you're struggling to motivate yourself
to do something but you feel like I've
got to do this thing but I can't I don't
really feel like it right now
I just don't do it yeah uh I mean yeah I
I try and think about like how I'm gonna
feel good afterwards I mean running for
example
I it's great I like to use running as a
tool to make me a better person if that
makes sense so like again this morning I
had to go and run because I wanted to be
in a good spirit for this and and so I
feel like if you can if you're doing
good things and you you've got to make a
real reason for them to exist and why
you do if if you don't really want to do
it and it's not going to help you then
don't do it but if it is going to help
you then just just think about how much
it's going to help I think is that does
that make any sense it does yeah I mean
I haven't done this stuff yeah
um a lot of people when they become
successful they they're like work-life
balance and like rest and but they don't
tell you that when for the first 10
years of their career they were like
grinding and
sort of had no balance at all how what
are your thoughts on work-life balance I
do actually think it's important I think
I'm very fortunate again like with what
I do to have people who who are so good
at what they do so I don't feel like I
have to constantly grind what about the
early days no I mean no I just didn't
stop but it didn't feel like a grind so
that's maybe the answer is like if it
feels like a ground
then it's probably you're not going to
be able to make it without burning out
but you could some people are grinding
because they're just on such a hike
because they love what they're doing or
they're seeing momentum and then you can
just keep going yeah I think I think
that's the thing like with a lot of
these like I've asked this question to
so many people like super successful
entrepreneurs and stuff and they're
always like yeah there's not a lot you
can do to get away from the fact that
especially in the early days you're
going to put in loads of work and if you
enjoy that work it doesn't feel like
work but if you're it's it's it's like
uh oh my friend uh Thiago Forte tweeted
like a few months ago that I often think
about which is that
you can't really outwork someone who For
Whom It Feels Like play or something
like that exactly like if I'm having fun
cracking Out YouTube videos and courses
and [ __ ] like there's no way someone who
considers that a grind is ever gonna
like get that same output so I don't
really like like the stuff on YouTube
which is like you gotta wake up at five
a.m no matter how upset you are with
your life you gotta do it
because like you could watch that was
that I don't know if that was good that
was my American uh YouTube accent yeah
but I just don't think I don't think
that's sustainable yeah maybe it's good
when you're on the treadmill to listen
to that kind of stuff but uh you you as
you said you've got to enjoy enjoy what
you're doing
um but also not you've got to remember
don't just walk away from something
because it's not fun one day you gotta
also like you're gonna go through tough
times and you gotta just keep pushing
um yeah how do you know so you've done
lots of project and stuff
um
how do you know when to quit something
versus when to like just keep going with
it because maybe you're in a bit of a
local Minima or dip
yeah I mean I I haven't quit that many
things so maybe I don't I'm not the best
person to answer this uh obviously okay
you'll be like well YouTube uh but I
feel like that goes after a long time
yeah so so most things I feel like I've
started I've still kind of you know
everything I've started five years ago
I'm still doing
um but how do you know when to quit if
it really isn't you know working or
bringing you any Joy I think that might
be a good time
uh but it really depends I need to look
at every situation and analyze it before
I can give like a broad piece of advice
like that I feel yeah
um very extensible yeah exactly but the
funny thing is
yeah but actually
quitting might be the best thing you
ever do not quitting might be the best
thing you ever do I feel like people
think if they just they think or they
ask for advice from someone that the
right answer is going to come back to
them but we can't tell what the future
is going to be you you know someone
could say you should you should have
quit Bitcoin in two thousand and 2019 or
whatever because it was really high and
it kept going and then they should have
said oh don't quit at the sun and it
just collapse you don't know when the
right time you don't really know these
things so I feel like
the answer is not to try and perfect
every decision it's just to make
decisions and even if they write 60 or
70 of the time at least you're moving in
the right direction but you'll make a
lot of mistakes along the way
and that's the same with like starting
something new don't try and make it
perfect before you release it because
it's just that's just not gonna work
yeah yeah
we released an episode recently with a
professional poker player there we go
and he talked about how in poco you have
to make zillion zillions of these
decisions and I was literally thinking
about poker all right yeah so what I was
going to think of saying there is like I
heard something the other day when
someone someone got bluffed off a hand
and they were like they were like happy
about it they had the best hand but they
folded to someone with a worse hand and
they were happy about it I was like why
why are you well why are you happy about
it It's like because
if if you're if you can't be bluffed off
a hand you'll be a terrible poker player
even your even though you're wrong
sometimes you'll be wrong
that's that's if you're if you try if
you're never Bluff to the Head you'll
make mistakes because you'll think
everyone's trying to Bluff you and then
you'll call someone who's actually got a
good hand does that make sense it does
yeah and so I think poker has a lot of
yeah analogies we can use it's like the
the whether or not the decision was good
no is independent of the outcome exactly
because what matters is the information
you had at the time and the fact that
you made a decision exactly and
sometimes people have incredible
outcomes and they might have made some
terrible decisions and everyone rewards
them for it and thinks they're a genius
and like you you know when people are
successful in life I find like they end
up giving everyone tons of advice
because they've been successful but they
again it could have it could have been
their decisions it could have been the
right Market I think a successful
business is 60 the right Market 30 the
team and 10 like the unique idea but
everyone's like just think come up with
a perfect idea it's not you can't
predict the future yeah that's so true I
I think it's sort of that just sparked
an idea an idea I think was it like
Coca-Cola or something like in the world
of marketing where they say that 20 of
our marketing campaigns need to fail and
if they're not we're not big there we go
Innovative that's exactly it and I also
think like I feel like I should apply
that advice to my own YouTube channel
yeah where like earlier today I was
meant to film a video of Mentos strong
word but like I was aiming to film a
video but I was just overthinking that
how do I perfect the hook yeah it's like
oh if you don't get people after the
first 30 seconds like who cares watch
time blah blah blah blah but it's like I
should have just filmed the freaking
thing and just spoken from the heart and
not had so much of like not being so
precious about like oh I really need
this to be good that's what I I am a bit
afraid with social media being all about
watch time what that does to
just allowing for differences to occur
I think everything has to be every no I
know that the content's all very
different but you can almost see the
formula happening in front of you as a
viewer and I think people are going to
eventually get a little tired of that
and I wonder what happens when you get
tired of the perfect watch time formula
like do people then have to do something
different
it's because like just like screaming at
you in the beginning to try and get you
to like get excited about it and then
keep you no matter there's not a second
you get bored
I feel like people will push away from
that eventually and I am starting to see
actually some more kind of slow paced
videos doing really well on YouTube too
so I guess it depends how you're
watching the video if you're watching on
your phone or on the TV but
yeah it's it's definitely not the it's
not my favorite content to watch that
that that stuff that's going to catch as
many people as possible within the watch
time algorithm yeah yeah there was
someone I'm speaking to like just on a
similar note I can't remember who it was
recently on the partner who said
something like when they train people in
sales or in lead generation they say
that your job is to get 99 rejections
yeah and they never get to that number
because people always say yes oh [ __ ] I
got six rejections I'm like four yeses
and now I've made my yeah and I've been
able to quit my job that's exactly and
that that is like life you you just you
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
love it
that I took that from the basketball
player but uh yeah it's it is really my
favorite
um kind of quote because
you just got to take enough shots and
you'll get lucky eventually hopefully I
mean that's what roulette taught me
relax
he played roulette I said something in
my life nice eventually hit zero if you
play enough
oh no normal relaxation but you do lose
money eventually yeah
um any books that you recommend fiction
non-fiction anything anything I should
check out oh uh Happy by Darren Ross I
love it it's one of my favorite books so
good Darren Brown is a dream guest
having the podcast yeah he'll he would
he'd be great yeah
I just yeah I love it
um it's quite like dense
right I think when I thought of Darren
Brown I didn't think of this guy posted
so much about this space yeah uh but
yeah it was it was brilliant it was also
quite easy uh there's a book called the
politics of geography
uh have you heard of that the politics
of geography hopefully I've got the name
right prisoners of geography prisoners
of geography thank you I think Angus
recommended that to me the other day I
think I've got it on Audible
it actually explains like they talked
about a lot of things we're experiencing
today and this was written like 10 years
ago
um it's it's all about how
uh where your country is situated in the
world and uh you know the geography in
which it lies really impacts the
politics
um and kind of the decisions and
outcomes of why certain places are so
successful versus others and and so on
it's quite scary actually it almost it's
almost like uh nature of a nurture kind
of stuff yeah you just realize like are
we all destined for things based on
where our country is in the world yeah I
guess that would have resonate with you
in particular like being in from South
Africa yeah like no I mean yeah it's all
about how yeah different if you've been
born in like a different neighborhood
suddenly we would be sitting here like
me as well like exactly exactly mental
anything else a happy person do you have
anything uh oh I have I've recently read
a book called The Go Giver trying to see
if you have any other the go-giver yeah
it's actually sick so one of our podcast
guests recommended it like two days ago
and I started listening to it but then
turns out that one of our team members
actually sent me a copy before he
started working for us how many books do
you read a month I think I average about
one or two a week wow but I ought to
build most things at like three times
speed so it's a bit it's a bit so I'm
yeah I've become quite bad actually I
started just reading the Ft now oh have
you checked you out yeah I know that's
when you know you run a fund
it's quite bad because my partner as
well like every time I have like like a
cool story I want to share with him he's
like I've already read that yeah like
[ __ ] there's only like 10 articles so
um no it's actually I I do recommend not
not the Ft but I recommend
um if you can get a subscription to or
or just read a newspaper it might also
bring a bit of unhappiness but I feel
like there's so much you can learn that
you don't you don't pick up instantly
but over time you're like oh wow there's
a lot more I can talk about because I'm
I'm reading about this stuff every day
but I Love non-fiction as well that's
probably why I read the yeah I was at a
I was at a conference in the retreating
over the weekend with a someone who's
like a senior editor at Time Magazine
and I asked her like what are the what
are the things I should read and she
said okay the the key is to read
magazine articles like Economist timing
all that kind of stuff because those
those are like really worked on yeah
okay that's a really good point yeah
whereas newspapers they haven't it's too
quick they don't have time to fact check
the blog post like who cares because I
feel the Ft the ft is like basically
yeah she recommended ft she was like
yeah it's like it's like gonna be a
complete fact no good news and it's
quite boring factual articles yeah or is
those what you're talking about they've
allowed there are people to spend time
even though it's coming out every day
they don't have that many stories my
understanding is that in the Ft there is
a section of like how rich people spend
their money oh yeah it's called yeah
it's literally yeah it's called
htstm or something they had to change
they had to make it an acronym because
it sounded a little bit I think it's
hard to spend them how to spend your
money is what it's meant to be so on the
on that note what have been some
purchases that have added
disproportionate value to your life
cheap expensive it could be anything
just anything disproportionate values a
purchase you've made that you've been
like you know people say that things
don't make you happy but but actually
the Woolen socks yeah
I started knitting so knitting nice
um the Ft subscription excellent uh what
are you trying to think gifts I've given
my girlfriend have helped a lot like
jewelry because I can remind every time
I see it I'm like you remember that yeah
I got you that
so that those sorts of things um to be
honest I'm a big fan of watches I I only
um I only have one kind of watch right
now but yeah I like I like I like
watches uh as like an investment vehicle
something to worry about I like the fact
that I'm also trying to work out what
which watch is gonna work in terms of an
investment so it's kind of for both it's
like I enjoy the way it looks but I like
the fact that it's going up in value
even though I probably won't sell it I I
kind of like the game of that well the
worst thing I ever bought was probably
uh a golf bag because it's so
frustrating do you play golf I do oh you
do and uh it is it's called fun I've
been thinking I'm getting ready yeah
I've heard it I've heard I should take
lessons
yeah I feel like you read my mind I was
gonna say
don't do what I did which is think oh
you're going to be brilliant and then
you just completely create a weird swing
and uh
yeah you end up just yeah I'm still bad
after like three four years of playing
golf
so it feels like one of those things
that there's like a clear learning curve
but it's also a game you can play up and
until you're seven it's it's great and
it's great for the yeah clearing the
mind and driving range yeah it is it is
good fun and
yeah yeah it's it's addictive I think
because you you know you hit loads of
bad shots but then every now and then
you get the perfect shot and it's just
like you're crazy yeah yeah it's about
having struggles yeah something
difficult you need something for me to
do if Casper's saying golf is a struggle
some first of all problems um no it
feels like a good thing to do with with
friends on a weekend just like you're
kind of you've kind of you kind of got a
thing to do and you just chat and like
walk around it's outdoors it's nice yeah
yeah 100 oh well with me and my friends
we're just like like really competitive
so we don't talk we just like oh wow we
just like yeah and like try and put each
other off and yeah things like that it's
quite but then at the end of the day
we're all happy damn
okay I'm gonna get some recommendations
get lessons for like two years and we
can play golf for two years okay first
I'll hit you up two years from now be
like right because then you'll be on my
level of uh finally competing at 90. um
that's my best score nice I don't know
what that means but no
it means you on a golf course you uh
it's usually 72 is how you should go
around a golf courses how many shots you
should hit okay and so like whenever you
go over that should be your handicap so
if you shoot 90 that's like 18 handicap
and then you play against someone who
goes who shoots maybe 74 and they're
like a two handicap and then you can
play with them does that make sense oh
yeah makes sense all the golf fans out
there buddy yeah I hope you enjoyed that
excellent excellent thank you so much
thank you it's been wonderful hope it
was any any final uh any final words of
wisdom from my nose is itchy and I think
it is from this cake
so I'm gonna have more but I think
there's something in this cake I'm
allergic to you're just gonna just scram
another muscle as they say well you've
got a cake in your mouth uh any any
final parting words of wisdom for people
who I might have listened to all two
hours of this
um hi Mom uh if we return my messages
please
um parting words of wisdom you miss 100
of the shots you don't take
love it thank you very much
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye